good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight it was a happy day
in america a beautiful july day and then
this afternoon something grave happened
joe biden made a very disturbing
announcement
this country faces a crisis more
dangerous than anything since the
american civil war
biden said that is gettysburg shiloh
antietam the walking dead of
andersonville
the killing fields of the 19th century
american south
that's what we're looking at right now
announce the president of the united
states
by attempting to pass laws requiring
voters to show id
when they vote republicans are risking
permanent
internal division as well as violent
conflict
think we're overstating here's what he
said
there's an unfolding assault
taking place in america today an attempt
to suppress and subvert
the right to vote and fair and free
elections
we're facing the most significant test
of our democracy
since the civil war that's not hyperbole
since the civil war
the civil war sound overheated to you
joe biden like you to know this is not
hyperbole
voter id laws are literally like the
civil war that is habeas corpus
suspended state legislatures shut down
hundreds of thousands of americans dead
in fields
that was the civil war biden made it
clear that's what he meant
he said it twice when was the last time
a sitting american president gave a
speech like this
well probably not since the 1860s during
the actual civil war
so it's hard to know how to process it
even allowing for the dementia
it was a stunningly irresponsible thing
for an american leader to say out loud
dangerous even so on what grounds did
joe biden say it what drove him to it
well here's the fort sumter biden was
referring to
yesterday 51 democrats in the state
legislature in texas
left texas and flew to washington d.c on
private jets
they did this in order to deny the texas
legislature a quorum
and then they shut it down they shut
down the democratic process
in their state by leaving texas they in
other words violated their sworn duty to
represent their voters
and they committed what amounted to an
act of yes insurrection
why so that texas lawmakers couldn't
pass laws against voter fraud
laws by the way that voters in texas
have said overwhelmingly
they want past that's democracy but
they're not getting it
the measures that texas voters would
like to see become law include a bill
that requires some form of
identification a driver's license a
social security card something valid and
real
for voters who submit mail-in ballots
another bill would require the texas
secretary of state to review voter rolls
for non-citizens
and remove people who are not allowed to
vote
so nothing in the bill is radical or
without extensive precedent if you
oppose voter fraud in fact it's all very
obvious
and not controversial at all and that's
why it's so popular with voters in texas
but democrats in the state don't oppose
voter fraud
nor critically do they believe in
multi-party politics
so they stopped the entire process cold
now preventing lawmakers from making
laws
shutting down the vote would not seem
like a defense of democracy in fact it
would appear to be just the opposite it
would appear to be an assault on the
very core
of democracy which is the legislature
the people's house
even diabolic old vladimir putin never
attempted to do that
but according to joe biden this time
it's necessary
sometimes you've got to end democracy in
order to save democracy that is if
you're not a racist
requiring people to prove their identity
when they cast a vote said the president
is quote
an unrelenting 21st century jim crow
assault
really how so but i'd never
explained but he didn't need to his
bootlickers on cable television jumped
in to do the talking for him
texas democrats taking a major stand for
voting rights
it is a dramatic yet effective move that
the national democratic party would do
well to try and pay attention to leaving
their legislative chamber without a
quorum was the last
best thing they thought they could do to
preserve voting rights there and try to
defeat the republican voter suppression
bill
the texas democrats fighting back in the
face of republicans very successful
voter suppression drive
texas democrats fleeing their state in a
last-ditch effort to block a restrictive
new voting law
as the gop is pushing its assault on our
most sacred right as americans
the right to vote who cares about the
last guy what about the first guy the
republican voter suppression act
how exactly do these bills suppress
voting precisely
well brian williams never told us he
just repeated the talking point he was
handed
what a brainless shill he has become so
many have but pay no attention to the
dead-eyed news anchor telling you the
usual lies
no consider instead the heroes of modern
texas the people
saving the vote by stopping the vote
preserving democracy by ending it
here's a picture of them on a charter
bus to the private airfield the
fbo as they say in private equity now
they may be smiling in the picture but
it's only to mask the pain inside
they may be drinking miller light but
it's not in celebration no it's in
solidarity with the campesinos and
campesinas around the state of texas
on whose behalf they were drinking those
beers the people who may not be
actual citizens of the united states who
may not speak our language or follow our
laws
but who still somehow have the god-given
right to choose your government for you
the right in other words to vote
democrat whenever they want
so it was an intense moment on that bus
picture che guevara sailing into havana
harbor on the grand ma to bring the
revolution to its bloody climax
and it only got more intense when the
charter buses arrived at the fbo
one texas lawmaker a childlike former
teacher called james talarico
tweeted about the dangers from his
private jet quote
just landed in memphis on our way to dc
thank you all for your well wishes
we left behind our families our
livelihoods and our beloved texas
but our sacrifice sorry can't read it
with a straight face
but our sacrifice is nothing compared to
the sacrifices brave americans have made
throughout history to protect the sacred
right to vote
those sacrifices included drinking
miller light on a private plane
over memphis it was moving now we don't
have a lot of photos from within that
private plane just like we don't have a
lot of paintings from washington's
crossing of the delaware
sometimes you have to imagine it but we
do have this documentary evidence this
shot and as you can see
those people are terrified they're not
taking this trip on a private plane for
themselves
they're doing it for democracy which
paradoxically they've just suspended
revolutions are full of bitter little
ironies like that but we learn to live
with them in the name of the greater
good
now you may be wondering how did all
those lawmakers
get on that plane can you just walk on a
plane now
doesn't that require some form of photo
id
a racist id card and by the way wear
their masks
aren't you required by federal law to
wear a mask on an airplane
sure you are in normal times but when
there's a revolution in progress
normal rules are suspended che guevara
never wore a surgical mask
his rifle was his id card
and so with these slightly chunky
revolutionary heroes
now once the brigade from texas finally
arrived in the capital city washington
they weren't met with artillery fire or
hessian sharpshooters no something more
daunting there were television cameras
awaiting their arrival
how did they handle this with the power
of song
we will overcome
[Music]
what happens when a cliche becomes so
time worn that it folds
in on itself like a cliche black hole
and sucks all of reality
into itself that's what you just saw
now but to the untrained eye the footage
we just played might seem a little bit
self-aggrandizing
it might seem like those lawmakers may
be the only ones on earth who appreciate
their own bravery and the sound of their
own voices
but that's not true there are still
other people in this country who
recognize how truly heroic
these political leaders are one texas
lawmaker
jean wu insisted that his fans couldn't
wait to see him when he got to
washington quote
landed safely in dc i was
it was wonderful to randomly run into
people who recognize
me and applauded what we are doing
now none of the people who are
vigorously applauding jean woo
a fear appear visible in that tweet but
you can rest assured mr mrs america
they're out there
they're just at a camera shot now
presumably jean woo's many fans as
legions of fans were also applauding as
he sat
eating lunch in the airport dining area
wu documented exactly what he ate in a
follow-up tweet just for the historical
record
quote my first meal as a fugitive
delicious
at some point in the modern era it
becomes a little hard to distinguish
between
hero and clinical narcissist
star of tick-tock videos
state legislator but whatever those
distinctions don't mean anything
gene wu is a hero for eating those
croutons how big a hero well jin wu
himself wouldn't say he's a man of
modesty
obviously but another representative
from the state of texas a fellow called
trey martinez fisher
spelled it out for us according to trey
martinez fisher can that name be real
we're going with it jean wu eating salad
in an airport
is very much like the civil rights
leaders of old
crossing the bridge in alabama taking
trench and blows to the head you watch
this is the risk that we take to stand
up for democracy i mean we are talking
about voting rights here
there were people who were beaten with
clubs and attacked by dogs and people
were murdered to protect the sacred
rights so this
this threat and this fingerprinting by
the governor you know is not going to
intimidate all of us we are strong and
united
and we want to bring you know voting
rights reform to this country
edmund pettus bridge chipotle same idea
different era as you'd expect kamala
harris wants in on the action she's been
protesting for civil rights since a
child growing up in canada sorry america
since two years old she's been demanding
freedom as she said so she's just
announced she's going to meet with these
freedom fighters sometime this week
the governor of texas greg abbott
meanwhile won't be there he has promised
to arrest them and bring them
back to the state house if they ever
return to texas so are they coming back
to texas no they're not
not until the session's over so
effectively these freedom fighters these
modern che guevaras
these crossers of the edmund pettus
bridge slash chipotle
have shut down texas's democratically
elected government
that's how you know they're defending
democracy that in the private planes
brit hume covers hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else